uh now
a mother who left her family including
her husband to flee from the war in
ukraine with her seven-year-old daughter
has become one of the first people to
find a home through the new sponsorship
routes here in the uk niara and her
daughter eleonora are with us now hello
to you both
hi good morning hi good morning hello
tell me about your journey
um i must say that
we woke up at five o'clock in the
morning
like others people in ukraine
and
we didn't know that they would invade us
and we understood with our husband
that russia invaded us
so after
like
many nights at vitro in our apartment
we experienced
like horror because
the military jets who were flying like
uh over our house and they bombed our
school they
killed our neighbors and after all these
days like we were then there in kharkiv
till
uh march 4th
uh we flee
we fleet ukraine we left our husband and
father there our relatives
and now we are in holland so
we passed uh levief who passed krakow
for
berlin because there are many refugees
and we didn't know where to sleep there
uh also my child was
i had a pneumonia so currently she is
okay
um why we stayed so long in hercules
because she uh
she was ill and we made injections to
her
uh
and then we we've come to holland and on
sunday or monday i published the post i
asked
for
for a home or shelter uh
from the uk people and simon
uh with dawn they uh
they send us a message and uh propose
their help
so right now we are waiting for uh for
to come to the uk
for now uh while the war is going on our
dad is a surgeon he is there he is
helping
uh to our people in ukraine however i
must say that there are many many women
and children
left on the east because right now as
uh like russia
is uh is trying to save for
russian-speaking uh families or people
and all these
women and children are just dying
because they are shooting them they are
shooting like
not only uh like
state infrastructures or buildings or
um
airports they bombing our like sleeping
quarters our houses
right now uh i know that today uh there
was like uh they destroyed a theater uh
in the marvel and in the basement of it
there were hundreds women with children
and we still don't know how they are
because our fight fighters
like god
like any other ambulances they cannot
reach them because
russians
shoot anybody uh and
by now we don't know how they are and i
know i know that right now in the town
near uh kharkiv
they bought a school in the center of
mariefa this is a town near a hearty
so they bombing uh all the night all day
uh and i must say that there are many
many civilians who live there because
for example i have my friend my my
lovely friend my
my shrink she's with
us uh seven dogs and cats uh she is uh
with his husband with her husband uh in
her kid she stayed there because she had
to stay there for that animals
other friends they're with their mothers
after post cavite and they cannot leave
they cannot flee as we did
um so i just i just
i just want that war and
and maybe someone will help us because
right now we we need
help so
children and women need help from uh
people in europe in the uk and i i know
that they helped they are so helpful
they are so amazing people in krakow we
met barbara
she watched us after like two weeks so
we've been in metro in in kharkiv
without any water uh to to be washed uh
so
then after krakow we uh made uh
we passed berlin we've seen
many refuges there uh and then our
friend in holland uh he invited us here
and we were sitting and just didn't know
what to do because there is no any
legislation for now for refugees
um and right now i heard about the uk
thanks guys maybe we will go there
but i must emphasize that
we need to we need to stop the war
because there are many many uh people in
ukraine ukraine is a big
for uh four million
population
country and
i don't know where they should go
because there are many poor many
uh
people with disabilities and they not
leave the country they are just left
there and that is why i'm here to to
tell the europe to tell the world that
we need your help or i guess euro
i guess ukraine deserves to be
to be alive to to win this uh this like
without any reason war yeah you've done
that very comprehensively and yara thank
you so much indeed and i can see you've
got your hands full as well i'm glad
that eleanor is recovered now from
pneumonia safe journey to the uk thank
you for taking the time to talk to us on
the program thank you